hey there welcome to con O'Brien needs a
friend joined by my crew my posi my
gang Matt gorley sonum obsess nice to
have you guys here good to ride with you
again yeah yeah ride free or die I
always say yeah I've never said that
ride or die is that what you mean ride
free I was thinking Live Free or Die
you're thinking of Live Free or Die Hard
the uh this posy sucks no it's live free
and die hard or Live Free or Die Hard
Live Free or Die Hard God worst guess
what we just won the award I was just
contacted worst podcast open ever we did
we just got it we just got it I think we
can do better this review the host
quibbled over whether it's live free and
die hard or Live Free or Die Hard never
even mentioning the film itself it was a
muddled Tangled mess it went on for 10
minutes and then this reviewer's review
was read off of an
iPhone can we get a fact check on that
I'm getting the fact check right now and
it's verified it's Live Free or Die hard
not to be confused with a Good Day to
Die Hard the fifth installment uh yes oh
then as gorle continues the theme I
can't believe this review came out so
quickly as we're doing it as gorle
continued the theme the segment became
even more flaccid Tangled and
self-referential A Good Day to Die limp
there we go gorle went even
further the Imp who never takes a queue
kepts chucking
out different version of Good Times die
hard until the whole thing was literal
oral
diarrhea uh wow this is man this is uh
this is serious this is slate and still
a better review than Good Day to Die
Hard yeah exactly and just when you
thought it was over gorley continued it
one last time for the ultimate call back
this reviewer is now taking his life
that's crazy oh wait a minute look go
has popped up an obituary oh yes
prominent reviewer for slate takes own
life this is crazy prominent
reviewer for of podcast reviewer for
slate took their own life just after
finishing a takedown of Conor Brien
needs a friend I love that you're
actually miming the swiping of the phone
am I'm scrolling up because I'm a i to
have good space work and this is all
really happening yeah yeah
in a first O'Brien read the obituary for
the fake podcaster from the fake Slate
review while miming swiping up on his
screen this is incredible very specific
incredible well uh agile Minds I suppose
agile Minds we got them
you hey look we don't have a lot of time
but I do want to point out some other
great people that are always here in the
booth with us making this happen the
great Adam Sachs wonderkind who got us
into the whole world without whom I
would be virtually unknown except for
the almost 30 years of Fame beforeand
and then uh Eduardo doing a great job
killing it Eduardo designed this uh
Sound Studio made it perfect and then uh
of course uh blle blle Is Here Yeah and
uh huh I wonder why I brought him wonder
he designed this studio and bla is here
well also blle is here but bla has been
with me for a long time bla came on is
you were a kid when you came on bla
that's right right out of college 2001 a
22-year-old fresh out of the oven that's
right and uh that was a long time ago
yeah it was yeah 20 yeah 20 bring us up
for a reason because we were talking
about it just before the podcast some
would say I'm jamming this in to the
conversation but you still dressed like
a child it's your generation
man yeah you know in World War II
20-year-old stormed Beaches they had
their lives cut short defending America
and you're wearing what is that t-shirt
I I don't it's got a you wear ironic
watches that are plastic and you wear
well now I've switched to bracelet is
that a Taylor Swift friendship bracel no
these are just these are bra these are
just uh bracelets you know I got these
in Thailand I got these okay whatever I
want to know where the real men have
gone look at you every time you're
always walking around you've got a kooky
backpack and you've got little you know
uh I know I look I have holes in my je
that's Bo you're just stepping in it now
did you pay extra for the hole in your
jeans was that extra I will say oh that
I've worked here for for a number of
years and uh and and I like to dress uh
I have my own style but I would be lying
if I said there wasn't a whisper every
morning when I put my clothes on oh yeah
what is going I know that every morning
do too you've done that to everybody
what's that movie where I think it's Die
Hard stop saying Die Hard where uh I
think it's the never- ending story where
the kid has to walk by these statues and
they might open up and obliterate them
with ey beams or whatever and it's like
the eye of saon it's like coming to work
every day I know the eye of Sauron is
going to PE my only question is this and
it's is just for your entire generation
okay okay can't wait to answer no but
isn't there a time for us to grow up I
think other Generations had to go
through the depression and they had to
go through I mean just terrible events
the Civil War everything and they were
they were forced to become men early
what did you go through oh please don't
even get into what have you done well I
was I went through the the cancellation
of the show CHiPs oh God I watched a
great show about two motorcycling
policemen in Los Angeles go away you
know what that was like I watched Gerald
Ford stumble on a tarmat do you know
what that does to a little
boy I had terrible terrible things
happen to me like what else what else
has happened please what else nothing
has happened like that's not enough no
the sunscreen I used as a boy was not
nearly up to Snuff
and I'm paying for it now by having
things removed from my neck because that
some scream was probably the equivalent
of an SPF 10 not an SPF 50 which is what
I should be had according to my person
who works on my
face I have a whole team that crafts
this body I have suffered and I am a man
because I went through things and bla
look at you well okay let me ask you a
question then how do you think I should
D what would be the ideal ever worn a
suit I think when you go to a funeral
for a loved one you're wearing a hoof
farted
t-shirt a backwards baseball cap that
says what me worry I don't know how some
puffy sneakers and then you've got like
seven watches that are all plastic isn't
it funny they don't tell time quipped
ble can you just take a look around this
room though cuz I I am wondering how you
made it this far with shirts like that
we have all just relegated ourselves to
Gap Basics because the way to be
invisible in front of this man that's
true no um Sona I've only criticized you
for only having one leather jacket for
the last 25 years well that's a high
class snub I know no I'm saying it's it
just looks like the one that uh the
general war in Planet of the
Apes it's got little ridges on the on
the I supposed to replace it like every
few months just one other jacket that's
all get out here you do have that that
kind of Boomer trait of you have to
comment on everything the way everybody
looks and the way they live their lives
ex I'm not a Boer you
not I am not a boomer you're like my
parents I'm genen Y no you're not you're
not yeah as in why the am I working
with you
people I'm I'm self-conscious now is
there an age that you think we should
stop wearing baseball cap no no no
that's always cool Eduardo um okay no it
has you know what and by the way that's
a football cap has everything to do no
it's cuz you you you think Eduardo's
cool and you like to beat up on blade
that's not it I really do have an issue
with bla bla I'm worried you're you're
always going to be a child and I don't
want to visit you in a nursing home cuz
I'm going to live forever well I don't
want to visit you in a nursing home and
he's like oh he's over there and you're
you know what I mean you're dressed like
a like a 16-year-old Korean school girl
I would like to see who's who's gone to
a club you know what I mean I mean and
you're like oh this person on my t-shirt
that's
uishi he's a little squiggly doodly I
love the squiggly doodies I watch them
every Saturday morning oh I don't know
where to in this yeah they the obish has
some good merch you got Adit you're on
my side a little bit no I'm on team bla
I'm on team bla I just don't think you
get I don't think you get it you get it
completely you don't get it and you hate
it no no no I get it completely it's a
it's a little story called Peter Pan I
Won't Grow Up I don't want to go to
school just a parent and I'll falely
rule I'll dress like BL every day well
can I say a thing which is oh why even
going to say that when you open your
closet to get dressed in the morning I
bet there's all kinds of like plastic
hats goofy things come tumbling out of
your closet your wardrobe animated and
it speaks to you yeah no no uh it's not
animated but that is true actually today
I had to go through a whole pile of hats
what are you doing what are you doing
let let him dig his own this is what I
was going to say which is which is uh
this is a bad analogy but you know
Batman the reason why Batman wears can I
just speak y the reason why Batman wears
a big bat on his chest is because that's
where the armor is thickest so people
will shoot at the bat okay so I'm like
the bat symbol on his chest it's from
The Dark Knight Returns but it uh so
basically everyone else should be
thanking me because I am drawing his
iron for you but I don't want that for
I'm jumping on the fashion grenade so to
speak for the office but we shouldn't
have to do that you know what I mean we
I just I take a little I'm just a little
worried about you blade because you came
to work with me as a young man and I
thought oh this is cool I like this
young guy maybe he'll stick with me for
the Long Haul and that was 22 years ago
yes and if anything you dressed more
like a man then and now you've just
become like a theme park animal that's
running around you know's he hurting
them the other thing I'll say is you
know I lost a bunch of weight a couple
years ago and so now that allowed me I
could I only had a certain amount of
clothes to choose from when you're you
know 63 and you're a bigger guy you can
only so but now I'm like oh man that
looks cool that looks cool so I'm kind
of having a Renaissance cuz I could
never wear these kind of clothes when I
was younger sh on
himy no can I say one thing son he just
did this Jiu-Jitsu move where it now
looks like I'm weight shaming him which
is terrible that's a terrible thing you
just did to me first of all um yes you
did lose a lot of weight I just thought
uh that you had terrible
diarrhea I didn't realize that you went
on this regimen that both things can be
true yeah but uh that's my favorite diet
by the way um that's gonna that's going
to you know sweep the nation soon but
yes I I just want to see you in a suit
once just wear a suit was you know what
come in in a suit and we'll do a segment
about it okay yeah you know let's put
you in the mope even more sure I will
wear a suit I will dress up and that
doesn't mean and you can't put any pins
on it for like DC
or no you can no it's this is a bank
this from now on this whole podcast
Empire is a bank this is this is Bank of
America and I'm going to start dressing
a t-shirt I'm going to working on a
little Schooner right now okay that's oh
let's get him he look like oh that's not
going to go well silicon f Bruce Lee
that'll go
well good luck I've got a spoon I'm
going to go attack Bruce Lee you're
right I don't so so uh no I just think
Adam you think as the guy who really is
the power behind the throne don't you
think it' be a good idea like I'm a big
admirer and he's a friend of Jack White
because Jack White makes everyone around
him sort of dress up uh and and I think
that's really cool and it has this cool
effect when uh when you see Jack and his
gang they're all they all represent
they're they're all dressed for the
occasion and uh in me I just look like I
run a daycare center you're the most
casually dress of any of us today I am
but you have to admit mostly I wear a
tie a lot I mean today just happens to
be an off day yeah that I was going to
say is that like they it it starts at
the top right it starts with Jack White
and then they all I guess mirror their
style off of well I think he also tases
them if they don't I think you're
probably right but but what I'm saying
is uh don't you think maybe we should
start to have a dress code here where
you've got to have and we have to
pretend it's a bank in 1955 no that's
and people have to wear fedora hats like
like uh hats from the the stuff I got
mocked for in the first place this
podcast that was a couple years ago I
never wore a fedora this a a comedy
podcast why I think it's a good idea but
we'd have to work it into the budget
because we can't ask people to go and
buy now we talking so you have to figure
out I'll pay for it but it's have to be
very shittily made clothing I mean very
bad like stuff that if it rains the
color runs no I need a new leather
jacket uh I will give you one of my old
ones what no you're gigantic so what
that's not going to fit me it doesn't
matter buy me a new jacket um yeah I
want a new rivan
SUV okay thanks um buy his stuff no I'm
getting him the rivan I'm not getting
you a jacket those are more expensive
for a rivan I just think that this is a
comedy podcast and I I want to say on
the record I like how blade dresses and
I'm totally fine with it and I think
you're being a bully yeah thank
you I will I will dress up I will dress
up and come in and uh you you might
change yourself you might not like it no
I love the idea of BL coming in a suit
come in a suit one day it might freak
you out you know what I mean no and it's
not going to freak me out to see you
dress as an adult you're 72 years old
for Christ's sake it's time to you know
grow up a little
bit